- Wir haben etwas
sehr Merkwürdiges aufzuklären.
- "Macht Hip-Hop-Musik Käse
fruchtiger?"
"Käse bekommt
besonderen Geschmack durch Hip-Hop."
"Forschung mit Käse,
Hip-Hop macht größere Löcher."
Selbst die Tagesschau berichtete
von der musikalischen Käseforschung.
Danke an Daniel,
der uns diese Schlagzeile
per Twitter zugezwitschert hat,
weil er sich dachte: Hm...
Was passiert, wenn ich Käse während
der Reifung mit Musik beschalle?
Und kann ich diese Musik
am Ende wirklich schmecken?
Das klären wir in einer neuen Ausgabe
"Schlagzeilen
wissenschaftlich geprüft".
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2019)
Musik soll angeblich auf alles
Mögliche einen Einfluss haben:
auf das Pflanzen-Wachstum,
auf das Baby-Wachstum, hm...
* Musik *
# Denn Darling, alles ist Chemie.
Warum nicht auch auf Käse?
Das fragten sich
natürlich ein paar Schweizer.
Und zwar an der Hochschule
der Künste in Bern.
Es handelt sich nicht
um ein Forschungsinstitut,
sondern um eine Kunsthochschule.
Die machen regelmäßig
fancy Kunstprojekte rund um Bern.
Z.B. eine Klanginstallation
in einem Brunnen.
Das neueste Projekt
ist auch ein Kunstprojekt,
ist aber ziemlich
wissenschaftlich aufgezogen.
Wie bei einem ordentlichen
wissenschaftlichen Experiment üblich,
wurde eine Hypothese formuliert:
"Dass die unterschiedliche
Beschallung der Halbhartkäse
zu unterschiedlichen Ausprägungen
der sensorischen Eigenschaften
der Käse führt."
Auf Deutsch:
Eine klare Hypothese, die man sehr
schön experimentell untersuchen kann.
Hier die Track-List
zu diesem Experiment.
5 Musikstücke
verschiedener Genres, von Klassik...
* Klassische Musik *
...bis Hip-Hop.
* Hip-Hop-Musik *
Und dann noch
3 verschiedene Sinus-Töne,
also 3 reine Töne
unterschiedlicher Höhe.
Mit diesen insgesamt
8 verschiedenen Sounds
wurde Käse
während der Reifung beschallt,
in solchen Kisten,
die eigens dafür gebaut wurden.
Am Ende wurden die verschiedenen Käse
von einer Fachjury
geschmacklich beurteilt.
Dabei kam raus, dass der Hip-Hop-Käse
geschmacklich besonders hervorsticht.
Diese geschmackliche
Beurteilung durch die Jury
wurde auch nicht irgendwie gemacht.
"Die Beurteilung
erfolgte in Anlehnung
an eine Konsens-Profilprüfung
gemäß DIN EN I SO 13299.
Und das Ganze
wurde auf geschmacksneutralen
Kartontellern serviert
und mit 3-stelligen
Zufallszahlen codiert."
D.h.: Das Ganze war verblindet.
Das klingt eigentlich alles ganz
wissenschaftlich, das Problem ist:
Pro Sound wurde hier jeweils
nur ein Käselaib beschallt.
Es gab zwar noch einen Kontrollkäse,
also einen Referenzkäse,
der im Stillen reifte,
aber auch hiervon gab es nur einen.
Lasst mich das Problem
kurz ausführen,
denn das ist ein wichtiger Punkt
für allgemeines wissenschaftliches
Denken und Arbeiten.
Wie testet man
eine Hypothese in der Wissenschaft?
Man kann versuchen,
die Hypothese zu belegen.
Was man aber
normalerweise macht, ist,
die Hypothese
versuchen zu widerlegen.
Wir hatten das mal:
Für die Hypothese
"der Weihnachtsmann existiert"
gibt es viele Belege wie z.B.
Geschenke unterm Weihnachtsbaum
oder die vielen
Bilder und Geschichten.
Solange wir nur Belege suchen,
geht die Hypothese auf.
Erst wenn wir versuchen,
die Hypothese zu widerlegen,
indem man den Weihnachtsbaum
die ganze Nacht beobachtet,
um zu sehen, wer wirklich
die Geschenke drunter legt,
erst dann haben wir die Hypothese
wissenschaftlich geprüft.
Heißt: Eine haltbare Hypothese
muss nicht nur belegbar sein,
sondern auch
Widerlegungsversuchen standhalten.
In unserem Käse-Fall können wir
eine "Nullhypothese" aufstellen.
Sie lautet:
Es ist egal, mit welcher Musik
der Käse beschallt wird,
es hat keinen Einfluss
auf den Geschmack.
Diese Nullhypothese muss
man jetzt versuchen zu widerlegen.
Wenn ich jetzt diese 8 Sounds habe
und dafür 8 verschiedene Käselaibe
und einen Referenzlaib,
einen Kontrolllaib,
warum kann ich
mit diesen experimentellen Setup
die Nullhypothese nicht widerlegen?
Weil Käse und vor allem
Schweizer Käse ein Naturprodukt ist.
Und Naturprodukte
unterliegen natürlichen Schwankungen.
Die Zusammensetzung
verschiedener Naturprodukte
ist nicht exakt gleich.
Deswegen ist auch
der Geschmack nicht exakt gleich.
Beim Käse hängt
die Reifung von Mikroorganismen ab,
die darin wachsen.
Wenn im Käsekeller an verschiedenen
Ecken minimale Unterschiede bestehen,
in der Temperatur
oder der Feuchtigkeit,
beeinflusst das
die Aktivität der Mikroorganismen.
Selbst wenn man
die äußeren Bedingungen
perfekt kontrollieren könnte,
sind biologische Prozesse
nie exakt gleich.
Bedeutet: Unter der Annahme,
dass die Nullhypothese wahr ist,
also unter der Annahme,
dass Musik keinen Einfluss
auf den Geschmack hat,
so werden verschiedene Käselaibe
aus biologischen Gründen
kleine Unterschiede
in der Zusammensetzung
und im Geschmack haben.
Was war das Ergebnis des Experiments?
Es gibt Unterschiede.
- Nein. - Doch. - Ohh...
Die Nullhypothese ist mit diesem
Ergebnis überhaupt nicht widerlegt.
Allein der Versuchsaufbau
war dazu verurteilt,
am Ende nichts auszusagen.
Und all die Bemühungen,
das wissenschaftlich aufzuziehen,
sei es die Milch,
die vom selben Bauern stammte,
die Karton-Teller, die DIN-Normen,
sie haben sogar
die verschiedenen Käseproben
einem Lebensmittelchemiker gegeben,
der sie untersucht hat
und zum unglaublichen Ergebnis kam:
- Es gibt Unterschiede.
- Nein. - Doch. - Ohh...
Immerhin steht
folgender Disclaimer auf der Website:
"Die Unterschiede
sind allesamt eher klein."
Und: "Der Rückschluss,
dass diese Unterschiede
die Hypothese bestätigen,
heißt, eindeutig auf die Beschallung
von Musik zurückzuführen sind,
ist denkbar, aber nicht zwingend."
Und: "Um herauszufinden,
ob eine eindeutige Kausalität
zwischen der Beschallung
der Käselaibe mit Musik
und sensorisch wahrnehmbaren
Unterschieden besteht,
muss ein größer angelegter Versuch
durchgeführt werden."
Was kann die Hochschule der Künste
in Bern nächstes Mal besser machen?
Man braucht nicht einen,
sondern viele Referenz-Käselaibe,
die im Stillen reifen.
Denn nur so kann man herausfinden,
wie groß die natürlichen Schwankungen
von Laib zu Laib in diesem Keller
zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt sind.
Am besten hat man auch
noch mehrere Käselaibe pro Sound.
Denn je kleiner
die zu erwartenden Effekte,
desto größer muss
auch die Stichprobe sein,
damit wir diese Effekte überhaupt
sehen können. Falls welche da sind.
Vielleicht wird das Experiment
im großen Maßstab wiederholt,
denn bisher
wurde auch nicht widerlegt,
dass Musik einen Einfluss
auf die Reifung haben könnte.
Ich würde keine großen Effekte
erwarten, aber Schall ist Vibration.
Und Vibration könnte,
wie andere mechanische Einflüsse,
Auswirkungen auf biologische Prozesse
haben. Warum nicht.
Z.B. sorgt Wind dafür, dass Pflanzen
dicker und stabiler wachsen.
Und dass Sound
Mikroorganismen beeinflusst,
wurde tatsächlich
in mancher kleinen Studie untersucht.
Die Hypothese an sich
ist also eigentlich spannend.
Hip-Hop und Chemie
ist immer eine gute Kombi.
* Hip-Hop-Musik *
Jedenfalls, ich bin für
jede kuriose Forschung zu haben.
Wenn Wissenschaftler ausrechnen,
mit welchem Druck Pinguine kacken,
bin ich die Erste, die darüber
berichtet. Ihr kennt mich.
Aber wenn irgendein Kunstprojekt
als "Wissenschaft" verkauft wird,
dann geht es zu weit.
Im Ernst: Dass das Kunstprojekt
so wissenschaftlich anmutend
verkauft wird, ist die eine Sache.
Aber dass da auch so viel Medien,
auch seriöse, drauf reinfallen,
das ist schon hart.
Im letzten
"Prüf die Schlagzeile"-Video
habe ich bereits
die Pinguin-Studie erwähnt.
Viele von euch haben geschrieben:
Wo finde ich diese geniale Studie?
Die Studie war Inhalt
meines allerersten YouTube-Videos.
Das verlinke ich euch.
Hier kommt ihr zum letzten
"Prüf die Schlagzeile"-Video.
Und wenn ihr in Zukunft
Schlagzeilen seht,
die über unglaubliche
wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse
berichten, und ihr euch fragt: Hm...
Dann teilt diese Schlagzeile
gerne mit mir oder Lars auf Twitter
unter #prüfdieschlagzeile
Dann wird sie geprüft.
Bis nächste Woche.
Bis dahin: Bleibt sicher.